right the following numbers as complex
numbers and just as a little bit of
review a complex number is a number that
has a real part or an imaginary part or
I should let me make that clear has they
has a real part and an imaginary part so
if I I'm gonna write some variables here
a plus B I where a is real and B is real
this is a complex number this part right
over here is the real part that is the
real part of the number and this part
right over here is imaginary and why is
it imaginary because it is a scaled up
version of this special number the
imaginary unit it's the special number I
it scaled up by B in this case and you
may or may not already be familiar I
know it's kind of a wacky thing but the
definition of I says that I squared is
equal to negative 1 hey we didn't have
any numbers before where if we took the
square we get negative 1 now if you take
I squared you get negative 1 so what's
neat about imaginary numbers is that
they're squares are negative and what's
useful about them is it allows us to
solve a bunch of equations that we
couldn't have solved if you're only
looking for real solutions that has all
sorts of implications in engineering
especially and and other things like
physics and all the rest so right now
you just really have to go with this
definition you just have to go with this
definition in this one and as we do more
numbers and especially once you seem a
lot more engineering applications
hopefully you'll realize the value of of
I or the value of imaginary numbers so
going back to the problem write the
following numbers as complex so this
number right here this is just a plain
vanila negative 21 it just looks like a
real number to me well how do I write it
as a complex number well I write it as a
combination of a real and an imaginary
number so I could just write this as
negative 21 that's the real part plus 0
times I it 0 times I is 0 so it's still
just gonna be negative 21 we have no
imaginary part really so this is just
the complex version of it very
straightforward same thing down here 7i
is a is an imaginary number there's no
real part to this so we could call this
the real part here is just
zero so this is zero plus zero plus 7i